uh the leaks were fake you your leaks
are fake
it's true all of it
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka a
in this video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about the
latest episode of the mandalorian
the entry title of the jedi has a lot to
unpack from it
and it's actually directed by dave
filoni who you may know as the creator
of the clone wars
filoni has appeared as an x-wing pilot
earlier in the season
but it's nice that they gave him his own
fully fledged entry which does tie into
his own properties
he doesn't waste any time getting to
what fans want to see
and the episode opens on corvus with the
arrival of a character that will make
everyone's lightsaber light up
that is ahsoka tenno played by none
other than rosario dawson
now the last time that we saw the
character she was actually with sabine
wren
and the pair was searching for ezra
bridget neither are mentioned in this
episode
but that could hint towards what's
happened with the group
now there are two ways that you can look
at them being admitted
and either ahsoka and ren found ezra and
the latter pair went off together
or something has happened to sabine that
has split them up
personally i'm leaning more towards the
latter and it could tie in with the
soaker's quest which we learned is to
track down grand admiral thrawn
thrawn is a massive villain in the star
wars expanded universe
and who knows he may have random bridger
or he could be completely unrelated
now i did leak the entire plot of this
entry earlier in the week
and by the run time of the episode i
think we got everything right
i'll keep my ear to the ground to let
you know if i hear anything in addition
to what we got sent but for the meantime
it does seem like things could be going
into a spin-off show following ahsoka
as she attempts to get the bad guys i
did feel like that guy sticking his leg
in the shot last week
as i ruined everything with the leaks
but unfortunately the dark side got the
better of me
disney actually reached out to me
directly which is why i stopped replying
to comments on that video and
i have promised to stop leaking entire
episodes as
you know it ruins the efforts of people
behind the show and and a lot of
people in general just don't want things
spoiled for them anyway you don't care
what you do care about though is what's
going on in this episode
now as bokeh tan said ahsoka is located
near the city of caledon
but there's actually a big bad who's
devastated the town folks and the
surrounding area
when you hear the word forest planet you
immediately think of lush green areas
however corvus is a far cry from that
and it's a complete wasteland of rotten
trees and dirt
ahsoka has been trying to find out where
thrawn is from a character known as the
magistrate
who has completely devastated the
landscape the magistrate is actually
called morgan
and we learned that during the clone
wars her people were massacred
she survived and then used her anger to
fuel an industry that built the imperial
starfleet
morgan has plundered worlds in order to
carry this out and it's clear that she's
doing the same thing on corvus
henchman is also michael bean who you
may remember as kyle reese in the
terminator franchise
bean was a massive star in the 80s and
alongside the machine masterpiece he
also starred in aliens
i love that the series keeps getting
actors like this and
it just makes for some awesome tv that i
completely fangirl over i mean i mean
fanboy
fanboy over now i don't think i'm
exaggerating here or when i say this
opener is one of the best scenes in
mandalorian history
we watch as ahsoka cuts up the forces of
the magistrate with a dual white
lightsabers
now this style of fighting is actually
called your kai and ahsoka is also
amassed throughout the reverse health
style which we see her wield during this
entry
i've done a full breakdown of the
character which you should definitely
check out after this
but just to give you the 4-1-1 osaka was
a prominent character during the clone
wars who survived order 66
and watched the jedi fall from power
ahsoka was the padawan of anakin
skywalker
and she even references the character in
the episode when saying that she's seen
what can happen to the best of them
asaka actually stepped away from the
jedi due to her being framed for an
attack that she did not participate in
the jedi hunted her and she became a
fugitive for some time
and even referenced the movie starring
harrison ford and tommy lee jones
which i'm not kidding that you know what
that was a great little easter egg
anyway
though she proved her innocence she saw
another side to the order
and decided to step away from them which
led to her becoming
someone that neither identified as a
sith nor jedi
though she gets called it throughout the
episode i think this actually highlights
why she doesn't really want to train the
child
but we'll discuss that more as we get
into the video ahsoka also wears a cloak
for this return
and the last time we saw her she was
donning something similar though it was
a different color
i love the way that it kind of comes
full circle here with the white of that
turning darker
as we kind of get the idea that her more
hopeful side has been soured quite a bit
the magistrate forces also have similar
voice changes to what leia had in return
of the jedi
when she was disguised as a bounty
hunter all in all it's the perfect way
to kick start the entry
and ahsoka gives the magistrate an
ultimatum that
i would have been shaking over now osaka
says that she must surrender the
location of thrawn
or be destroyed i got a lot of vibes of
luke in return of the jedi
going to jabba to make a deal and the
magistrate to me
is very much a gangster that's came into
the area and taken over it
we also see droids similar to what jabba
had in his palace
and even the location that the
magistrate resides at is very similar to
the locale
now the magistrate is willing to kill as
many people as she needs to to get a
sucker to back off
but ahsoka won't do it it's an awesome
setup for the entry
and asaka gives her one day to decide
what to do
cut to the child of mando arriving at
the planet and we see a similar scene to
what we've had throughout the season
however this one evolves the little guy
in several ways
now he's still fascinated over that tiny
ball on the handle
however whereas in the past he would
have just unscrewed it
here he uses the force to do it showing
that he's becoming more confident with
his powers
he doesn't even mind stealing biscuits
at this point and almost wiping out
endangered species entirely
man screw this guy anyway cut to corvus
and we watch as mando approaches the
city
there's a guard using a tracking gun to
follow the ship and this brought up a
lot of imagery of a new hope for me
namely when a similar thing happened on
yavin 4. you also get to see some of the
local life that lives in the area
namely massive beasts that look slightly
like bigger dewbacks
they feast on the trees at the location
but as they've been stripped of their
leaves
it's unlikely that they're going to get
too full of them mando enters the city
and it doesn't seem like they take too
kindly to his kind around here
as he gets given a lot of funny eyes
before being called to the magistrate
mando passes an old woman at a market
stand who looked a lot like the old
woman at the end of rise of skywalker
but again could be reaching isn't the
first time
definitely won't be the last time he
also catches a man in his two kids
and i sense a great feature for this guy
now it's not long before he's called to
the magistrate and on the way there
we see a similar standing torture
devices to what were used on hero in
rebels
the magistrate offers mando a best score
spear in exchange for taking down ahsoka
and it's not too long before the pair
meet now as we've learned from several
characters throughout the season
best score is extremely rare at this
point and many people have tried to kill
mando
just for the fact that he has a lot of
it it of course repels lasers and
lightsabers
but prying it from the person's hand who
bears it is very difficult
so there's a high risk and reward to
trying to snatch it
mano goes out into the woods in order to
get ahsoka and you can also spot what
looks to be an owl in a tree
i may be reading into this but i think
that could be morai
though that's just me guessing anyway
this location kicks off a short but
sweet action scene
that sees the pair going head-to-head
now you can never get enough lightsabers
in the show
and seeing them duel it out using all
they have at their disposal
is an absolutely amazing moment mando
nearly gets his butt handed to him
but he brings up bokehtan to end the
fight before escalates any further
now it's here that we learn a lot of ins
and outs about the child's past
namely his name i am gonna miss calling
the little guy baby yoda
but we now have it confirmed that he's
in fact called grogu
when i announced this on my leak video i
had a lot of people saying he should be
called goku
that it should start with a y like yoda
and yaddle
but whatever the case this is now the
character's name
r.i.p baby yoda anyway after a circle
mine melts with him
we discover that the character was
actually trained at the jedi temple and
core ascent
before everything went to hell many
masters trained him over the years
but he was never assigned to just one
and nurses had a bit of a difficult past
at the end of the clone wars when the
empire rose to power he was hidden away
and though we don't know who was behind
this someone took him from the temple
and obviously i'd love to hear your
theories below on who you think this
could be
now there are rumors that we are getting
a mace windu spin-off series
but whether that's the case or not i i
don't really know
what i do know though is that grogu's
memory becomes dark
not too long after this and the
character in some ways was lost and
alone
ahsoka brings up a wise jedi master
named yoda from the same species as him
but as we know during the events of this
show the character is actually dead
groku has kind of shut himself off from
the force but ahsoka agrees to test him
cut to the next day and they go to an
area that has some plant life
and vegetation in it i got a lot of
dagobah vibes here and
along with the look to the area ahsoka
also uses rocks
similar to how yoda trained luke
unfortunately grogu doesn't seem that
interested in carrying out the test
and it's clear that he possesses a lot
of fear grow goo has hidden his
abilities over the years to survive
but he clearly has an affection for
mando mano manages to get it out of him
eventually when bringing the metal ball
from the ship
and i felt like i was watching a proud
dad play catch with his son
now it all looks good however ahsoka
says because of his attachment to mandel
that it's a bad idea to train him
these feelings can completely destroy
someone and should anything happen to
groggy's parental figure
it could lead him down a dark path we
did see something similar with anakin
when his mother died in attack of the
clones
and that was one of the many cogs that
was instrumental in turning the
character to the dark side
ahsoka says she's heading back to the
village which is when mando brings up
his deal
with the villain of the show who you
probably forgot about at this point
armando agrees to help ahsoka take down
the magistrate in exchange for pointing
him in the right direction
i love how mano mentions a mandalorian
and a jedi teaming up
as this was a combo that ahsoka did with
several characters over the years ahsoka
was actually one of the leading forces
behind mandalore's liberation
and she's teamed up with many of them to
do what we basically see here
as the final action scene for the
episode i love how bologna kind of uses
the limitations that cartoons often have
to display violence
and for example rather than cutting
someone in half we see them stand
in front of a horn which then gets split
in two and subtly suggests to us that
this
also happened to the person on the other
side of it it's inspired
choices like this that really elevate
the entry
and ahsoka faces off against the
magistrate whilst mando and michael stan
on the outside waiting for the outcome
of the fight
it's very much like this old timely
western and this slow draw
has some awesome back and forths to it
there's also a little lothcat cameo as
the soldiers are moving through the
streets
and overall it's an amazing way to close
out the entry
now as we said ahsoka is after the
location of thrawn and in case you don't
know who he is
he's basically the big bad that rose up
after the fall of the empire in the
expanded law
before we get into all that though i
just want to remind you that we do
videos like this
each and every day so if you're enjoying
it then please subscribe to the
channel oh come here you
anyway thrawn was a chissmail officer
who rose through the ranks of the
imperial navy
during the time of the galactic empire
due to his appearance he's quite an
unforgettable character
and along with his blue skin he has
cheekbones to die for
thrawn believed that to defeat one's
enemy you must understand them
unless he spent many years studying the
jedi and mandalorians
growing up thrawn was part of the
unknown regions and in order to discover
what was going on in the main galaxy
he traveled to it which is where he
stumbled across the clone wars and met
anakin
thrawn was uninterested in the democracy
of the senate as he thought that if
everyone had a voice that nothing would
get done
thus he initially rejected chancellor
palpatine's offer to join them
but when the galactic empire was formed
he decided to become an imperial
as this was more in line with his way of
thinking even though alien species are
not
normally that welcome in the imperial
ranks thrawn's ability far outweighed
any prejudices
and thus he became one of the key
members palpatine gave him the rank of
grand admiral personally
and from his ship to chimera he led the
seventh fleet
in the expanded universe he's gone after
luke several times
and also appeared in rebels thrawn is a
pivotal character
and he actually ended up helping to form
the first order which i think
this show or the spin-offs could
definitely set up he disappeared with
ezra at the end of rebels
so ahsoka is likely looking for him
purely because she thinks that the two
will still be together
anyway a new leader of kaladin is
appointed but he'll probably be just as
bad as the rest
yes it's politics yes we're going meta
mano takes this spear even though he
didn't complete the mission
and i guess this is the way now
maybe he's changing and hopefully we
will see him take his helmet off
also i love the panpipe version of the
theme which is very final fantasy 9
which
i completely love now mando heads out to
tython which contains the ancient runes
of a jedi temple
mando is told that if he puts groga on a
seeing stone at the top of the mountain
and he may be able to reach out to
another jedi but we don't know what this
entails
now i do think that it could be mace
windu as i've said earlier
but at this point it could also be
absolutely anyone else
i think we deserve a big character in it
and though many likely think he's dead
we never saw a body
and then order 66 happened so if it was
the character
i would have just bolted without saying
mother effer
could also be luke could be ezra bridger
could be anyone
let me know below anyway that concludes
another excellent episode of the
mandalorian
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the entry in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of who ahsoka to know
is
we tell you everything you need to know
about tenno
and it's great puns as well don't forget
we're also giving away three copies of
the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of november so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat who's on the
discord server linked in the description
or a heavy spoilers on twitter thanks
for making it until the end of the video
you've been the best
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
you